well you search what is one of the most  fascinating things to me I have looked  up to the sky from the time I was really  young and just  like it's the only it's a thing that  gives me a headache because I think it  goes on for Infinity but then what's at  the end of there's nothing it goes it  keeps going there must be an end but  what would that be and is that like what  you used to think when you were a kid  when you looked up to the sky now when I  looked up to the sky as a kid I looked  up and I thought one of those Stars  there's going to be a planet and there's  going to be some little kid on that  planet walking along with their parent  and seeing  seeing our star in their Sky our son as  a star in their sky and they're going to  be wondering whether anybody is up there  looking at them I agree with you I I my  opinion being that there's no way we're  alone like it's there's way too much  it's an awful waste of space